hey guys it is the 15th of May my name
is Jess Mattel and you're watching
Ubisoft news I'm sorry please what new
in what is very good news for Ubisoft
watch dogs is well on its way to
becoming the most successful new IP ever
like actually ever see you if kill Emma
said some bits and pieces today one of
which was to announce that watch dogs
pre-orders are at record levels they
won't tell us exactly how many have been
made to date but they had previously
shared the information that they expect
the game to sell around six million
units interestingly bungee is also
touting that their game destiny will be
the best selling new IP in video game
history so let me know which one you
think is more likely in news that
surprised absolutely nobody the division
that sweet shooter that we saw at e3
last year has been delayed till 2015 the
third person shooter set in person park
elliptic New York has been officially
pushed back but you may have declined to
explain why just yet they have promised
that more details about the title will
be unveiled during their e3 2014 media
briefing next month so at least we can
look what did that Ubisoft CEO Yves Gill
emma has said that he's very happy about
the xbox one Prescott and the unbundling
of the Kinect salimos said we think it's
a great move from Microsoft we expect
the next-gen to grow faster thanks to
that customers will have the possibility
to buy either with or without connect
and that will be a very positive thing
for the industry and rounding off what
is apparently our day of things that you
sort of said and done far cry 4 has been
officially announced predictably the
game will be coming to every non
nintendo platform including pc and both
sony and microsoft's current and last
generation consoles on november 18 2014
the news was confirmed by the bringer of
all news on the fifteenth of May Yves
Guillermo who said the year's
performance will be led by five games
Assassin's Creed unity far cry 4 just
dance the crew and watchdogs Ubisoft has
done some scene setting for the next
installment by stating in far cry 4
players find themselves in chi rat a
breathtaking perilous and while
region of the himalayas struggling under
the regime of a despotic self-appointed
king using a vast array of weapons
vehicles and animals players will write
their own story across an exotic
open-world landscape executive producer
dan hey has said they're trying to take
the franchise to the next level should
you want a pre-order you'll be able to
get a three-part single-player mission
pack featuring hook from Far Cry 3 and a
harpoon gun named the Impaler let me
know what you think about far cry 4 and
the antagonist soup color choices in
that commenting section down below or if
you prefer you can shut me directly on
Twitter where I'm at just McDonald that
is it for me today tomorrow i have my
top five stories of the whole week for
you and they won't be all about ubisoft
probably